new push to expand covet testing at
schools nationwide as omicron cases soar
overnight the bite administration
announced it will now give schools an
additional 10 million free covet tests
per month and it says that should allow
schools to more than double the number
of tests currently being performed it's
a push coming at a critical time with
many school districts stretched
desperately thin
students in chicago the nation's third
largest school district returned to
in-person learning today after a week at
home due to teacher safety concerns we
are joined now by america's education
secretary miguel cardona for an
interview you will see only on cbs
mornings mr secretary good morning to
you critical time here for for students
i would say parents as well as they look
to get back to their own new normal
how big of a difference do you think
this increase in testing is going to
make in schools ability to stay open and
educate our children
well thank you for having me first of
all
we're doing everything we can to make
sure that our children have an
opportunity to stay in school uh that's
where they need to be and we know we can
do it safely so this announcement uh is
uh further evidence that we're listening
and we're gonna do everything we can to
keep our schools open the tests but also
the connections with labs to make sure
that it's sustainable for our districts
is critically important as we keep our
kids in school
so you say you're listening but can you
deliver is the question there's a lot of
people at home right now thinking where
are they going to get 10 million tests
per month we're struggling to find them
in my own community so what's the answer
to that question where are these coming
from
you know the president made it clear
that through the defense act that
there's going to be higher production of
tests we're prioritizing our schools we
recognize that schools are the hubs of
the community that we should not be
closing our schools first as uh dr
wolinski said it's vital for our
students so you're going to see
distribution of tests as early as next
week to make sure that our schools can
stay open
so mr secretary as of right now you
don't have them stockpiled but they're
going to be made in the next seven days
the tests are being developed and uh
states are applying now to uh receive
these to the cdc so we do expect next
week that they will be out
all right you expect uh and how will
they be administered are these for all
staff teachers and students
well you know we're promoting the test
to stay program for those who are
unvaccinated and we know as the cdc new
guidance uh said we're not requiring
tests for everyone to come back in every
day i don't think that's a sustainable
model what we need to do is follow the
mitigation strategies that we know work
and where possible increase the number
of students and staff that are
vaccinated we know vaccinations are the
best tool that we have to fight this uh
omicron virus and covet 19 in general so
we must not only provide uh testing
where needed but also make sure that
we're increasing our vaccinations across
the country mr secretary where do you
stand on vaccination mandates the los
angeles unified school district for
example had one for children 5 to 11
planned and then they decided to push it
back deeper into the fall
i know it's a local decision but what's
your national opinion on whether schools
should go that route
yeah you know there are some logistical
issues with that as well uh
i know that they work listen what we've
seen across the country is that they
work and they're
helping reduce disruptions in our
schools um in terms of mandating it you
know i don't know what other what else
you need to help people understand i'm
starting to get concerned now of the
effects of what i'm hearing about
hospitalizations of the unvaccinated and
the impact that that's having on our
hospitals i think we have to really take
a look at that to make sure that we're
providing public health safety for
everyone
yeah mr secretary with all these rules
and coveted shutdowns and disruptions
school board meetings around the country
have gotten very heated in recent months
and back in september a letter was sent
to the white house from the national
school board association it's called
asking for help from the doj and fbi to
investigate threats against school board
members in fact comparing those threats
to domestic terrorism a few days later
attorney general eric garland issued a
memo saying that the doj and fbi would
in fact look into these threats now some
republicans have seized on this to say
the government is trying to intimidate
frustrated parents against speaking out
so the question to you i think is did
you solicit anything from that school
board association and should the doj and
fbi have gotten involved in this at all
you know we didn't uh ask for that
letter we didn't um i think the real
focus should be how do we authentically
engage parents and i think moving
forward we have to have a better
strategy across the country to listen to
parents
and to make sure that they're engaged in
the process uh but no specifically with
that letter we had no
uh we didn't request that or there was
no involvement in that
do you agree with the doj and fbi
involvement
i believe you know any threats toward
any elected officials is unacceptable
and whatever steps needs to be taken to
make sure that that doesn't happen
should be because i know especially
across the country our board members
oftentimes are volunteers that want to
help their community
and they should be protected
yeah it is a difficult situation for
people on both sides of the issue
secretary cordon we appreciate you
walking us through it all thank you
thank you